كورونا مجددا في قلب الجدل بين الغرب
والصين فقد اتسع طرقات الدول التي قررت
فرض اجراءات احترازيه على القادمين اليها
من الصين وذلك وسط مخاوف متصاعده من
انتشار موجه الاصابات التي تشهدها الصين
حاليا خارجا حدودها ومن ضمن تلك الاجراءات
فرض اختبار كرونا على جميع الوافدين من
الصين في هذه الاسماء حصه منظمه الصحه
على تقديم معلومات دقيقه ومحدثه بشان
الوضع الوبائي واكدت المنظمه على ضروره
مشاركه المنتظمه وفي الوقت الحقيقه
للبيانات الخاصه بالوضع الوبائي وبيانات
التطعيمات التي تم تقديمها للسكان في
الصين
قال ان بلاده قد دخلت مرحله جديده من
مكافحه الفايروس 19
جديده اكد ان تغلب على الجائحه بات قريبا
في الوقت الحاضر دخلت مكافحه الوباء
والوقايه منه مرحله جديده فالجميع يعمل
بجد والنصر القريب بمثابره ووحدتنا سوف
ننتصر